donc un tour cela
pour cela je vous prie de venir dans le
jardin la plus vite possible
voilà on oubliait veuillez accepter très
cher monsieur travelling veuillez
accepter mes salut casimir aisq sa lutte
ainsi me right voilà les églises ne
s'arrête pas françois tu écris une
lettre
oui j'écris net georges avec la vie
recyclage et paletot je vais jusqu'au
port pour pêcher la lumière mais france
on attend c'est intéressant et c'est
très vite lui bomba dépêche toi je suis
très pressé les vestiaires et coûtera
cher monsieur travelling derrière le
site rapplique comme en mai mai du écrit
à l'organisateur de spectacles qui veut
emmener à travers le monde comme un
horrible et pour monstres dans une cage
ouais c'est bien à lui oui mais là ce
mois a continué enfin voila j'ai bien
réfléchi à toutes vos propositions
je veux bien signer un contrat avec vous
pour cela je vous prie de venir dans le
jardin le plus vite possible
ça l'a assez bien écrit un non choix que
les miens étaient complètement fou mais
en fait si je signe le contrat de
monsieur travelling mais il va venir
immédiatement il va ton épique qui va
tenir dans une quinzaine
alors et alors mais qu'est signalée mais
tu seras plus avec nous tous
puis tu sais tu vas nous manquer on fait
quasiment tu pourrais quand même pensé
aux enfants qui chaque jour
régulièrement viennent te voir les émirs
surtout sans toit via l'île aux enfants
ne sera plus du tout la même
enfin moi je ne t'ai jamais demandé
comment était fabriquée des ballons
alors note occupa de ma vie
professionnelle savent à casimir ça va
j'ai compris nous rajoute plus je te
laisse après tous deux capables de faire
toutes les bêtises de la terre s est
fait plaisir
envoi à temps pour soi je devrais te
demander un petit service un service
oui je veux bien parce que ce sera sans
doute le dernier
qu'est ce que tu pourrais apporter cette
lettre je voudrais qu'elle pas très vite
à ses biens à contre coeur tu sais tu
n'as pas une enveloppe
ouais pourquoi alors donne la moitié
milliard d'euros 2 à moi c'est pour
mettre ta lettre à l'intérieur riel
enveloppe voilà merci du fait choir
japon casimir voyons si tout est prêt
d'accord ça va quand même pas encore
assez grand
alors monsieur travelling quelle
surprise je viens justement de vous
envoyer une lettre merveilleuse vient de
rencontrer votre ami françois qui me l'a
remise le nombre de têtes et pas mal moi
non non il vous des caches tu sais quoi
bon avant tandis gtoi bien mauvaise
qu'est ce qui me vaut l'honneur de votre
vie a le flair c'est rami le flair tous
les imprésarios comme moi doivent savoir
nice le très loin l'odeur d'un contrat
ou le talent d'un artiste est inutile
vous dire que le flair d'albert
travelling mois et le plus fin de tous
donc ce matin trempe au mont croissant
dans ma tasse de café au lait j'ai senti
un parfum bien le lien avec tourner
[Musique]
c'était le parfum d'un contrat qui
mijote j'ai aussitôt compris qu'il
s'agissait de vous j'ai pris le premier
bateau pour les aux enfants et me voilà
vous aide extraordinaire
dites-moi quand vous allez à la chasse
vous vous ne devez pas avoir besoin de
chiens pour trouver la parenthèse un
réseau ne jamais faire sur jean d'arcy
d'astuces dans un spectacle n'est ce pas
bon bon prix passons aux choses
sérieuses
je vous ai apporté un nouveau coma pour
m'envoyer au tour du monde enfermé dans
une cage
oui et non car je vous ai une petite
surprise j'adore les surprises bien ou
très bien fait bien bien je n'ai pas
voulu vous empêcher de santé alors j'ai
ajouté un supplément à votre numéro à la
main on ouvrira votre cage et vous
pourrez venir santé quelques jours valve
vous n'aurez que quelques scènes ok
juste pour empêcher le spectateur d'être
gagnés par la panique
c'est rageant qui avoue vous était
certain de faire plaisir vous verrez ce
sera sans ça c'est même sens assez net
des intérêts cutanée qui signe ici là
non mais pourquoi je ne veux pas chanter
nous voyons sur grands artistes [ __ ]
j'ai immédiatement relayé cela du
contrat va laisser faire et vous oui
j'aurais encore une question à vous
poser à m qu'est ce que je devrais faire
dans cette cage jeu ce pommeau vous en
proposera quelques ballons seulement
quelques gros m'enfin tout laisse carte
blanche il ya quelque chose dans ce
genre là un peu plus agressif potter oui
d'accord comme ça
d'accord je vais signer mais avec mon
stylo favori charmante aux côtés
d'artistes
voilà ça y est j'ai signé à vouloir
faire moi je signerai on voit la sesto
maintenant dit le contraire
non non ça n'est pas possible alors
casimir tu as signé le contrat de
monsieur travelling disons plutôt que
c'est monsieur travelling qui a signé
mon contrat jusque lui raconte je
changeais le contrat au dernier moment
sans qu'il s'en aperçoive et je lui
engagé comme en sandwich par un homme
sandwich
c'est formidable je traiterai splendide
à quelle allure et l'alluré
ah ah
[Musique]